un vrai décor de cinéma maintenant en
effet suite à la visite historique d'un
ancien président américain jimmy carter
à cuba on a pu constater que le pays
s'ouvre s'ouvrait au tourisme la ville
de la havane est un magnifique
témoignage de l'architecturé espagnol
mais elle est à l'image du pays délabré
depuis quelques années pourtant grâce au
fonds de l'unesco par exemple les
quartiers les plus prestigieux de la
havane sont réhabilités mais en même
temps la population pauvre on est exclu
reportage etienne les nains en diamants
c'est un peu comme si après des années
passées à dormir le quartier historique
de la havane et ses pierres vieilles de
500 ans respire est à nouveau un par un
les trésors longtemps délaissé d'une
architecture emprunté à l'espagne
retrouvent leur lustre d'antan
et s'il en est ainsi c'est que pour
survivre le régime communiste qui
n'avaient jamais fait de ses murs la
priorité de sa lutte ouvre aujourd'hui
ce territoire au tourisme et donc au
dollar quitte à prendre des libertés
avec les théoriciens de la révolution
pour ceux qui ont lutté avec les barbus
qui descendait des montagnes ceux qui
ont fait la révolution
il ya une prise de conscience qu'il y a
désormais une nouvelle manière de
trouver de l'argent
car derrière les façades restaurées les
hôtels de luxe se bousculent évidemment
une autre réalité celle des files
d'attentes pour obtenir les quelques
boules de pain quotidien
celle des privations les habitants de la
vieille havane vivent de plus en plus
mal ce fossé grandissant
d'autant que le programme de rénovation
encourage celles et ceux qui pour rien
au monde ne quitteraient leurs quartiers
à aller se reloger ailleurs sur la place
vieille par exemple un seul immeuble
fait encore de la résistance
mme oumou khairy glisse et autres bien
sûr des gens veulent bien parti mais les
autres ceux qui sont nés ici ou qui ne
veulent pas aller n'importe où cela
refuse dans notre immeuble ils vont
faire quinze appartements mais ils ne
veulent garder que les familles peu
nombreuse juste une ou deux personnes
depuis que l'union soviétique est morte
et enterrée la havane et c'est un
million et demi d'habitants manquent de
tout et ne peut plus compter que sur ses
propres forces a dit dollars le salaire
mensuel moyen
pedro pourrait espérer vendre à
l'étranger pour une petite fortune sa
superbe américaine une chevrolet de 1955
mais explique-t-il cela aussi lui est
interdit dans la lumière du soir sur le
malecon que les cubains surnomme
amoureusement leur promenade des anglais
on a vu apparaître ces derniers mois ces
petits taxis à touristes qui
progressivement remplaceront les
vieilles guimbardes au charme désuet
le signe sans doute que le voyageur en
quête d'authenticité doit se dépêcher de
visiter cuba au nom